hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Minecraft I have
built a farm and it is beautiful and I
am amazing for doing it people have
suggested that I add mods to my game to
make it run smoother but I say shut up
it's fine
shut up it's fine anyway Wow
ah as I wait for my glorious wheat to
grow I am going to embark on a mission
of incredible importance the likes of
which I've never seen before and will
never be reciprocated regretful rippln
imma make for some I forget your
username but I may have been more than
one but I only saw one someone was like
making fun of me someone was mocking me
me they were mocking me because my floor
is made of dirt number one how dare you
number two how dare you I will fix that
my door my door alright anyway lick
seeing time-lapse
[Music]
okay it's been dug I think these know
bad I'm sleeping above the ground
oh no doors okay we're fine this is
terrifying
I can't imagine sleeping without a door
look see and keep the time-lapse going
but make it really cool make it like the
coolest make it the sweetest time-lapse
anyone's ever seen make it so
unbelievably cool that everyone's gonna
watch this video and they're gonna be
like whoa that time-lapse that
time-lapse was sick that was like the
best time-lapse I've ever seen in my
life that was just a nuts time-lapse
from start to finish so um like I don't
know of more than just like cool music
and why not make it like something that
people will really remember forever and
I'm done okay that time-lapse better
have been good was it good thank you all
right and everything looks exactly the
same and I have no one problem at a time
I can't really fix everything in one so
I'm not gonna worry about the lack of
roof miss BAM boo this man so whatever
your name was Billy Jimmy
Jeremiah Abigail Stacey whatever your
name may have been I will not forget and
I will not forgive okay anyway now that
I've solved that problem now I will
embark on an epic quest the likes of
which I've never experienced before the
likes of which no one will ever see ever
again because I am going to
find a diamond I'm hoping that right now
lik seeing is like playing really epic
music and really building this up
because it's like a big deal and whatnot
yes it's true I go into the depths down
below to find that which lies lurking
down deep in the darkness below I may
never return that I may never want to
return after what I see down below
though I must and go I will what happens
to me down there in the darkness and the
brave may survive that's pretty cool
right that's pretty cool pretty cool I'm
good at the talking thing anyway I'm
gonna go down in this hole oh yeah I
made another hole wasn't I going to make
more hole I need more hole imma go down
until I can't go down no mo and we're
down but this isn't found nearly as mo
enough as it should be down I need to go
down much mo
[Music]
oh this bedrock that's what they call
bedrock baby now that I found the bottom
now that I know now now that I know that
now Wow now that I have found the bottom
now but now that I found the bottom now
I know the depths that I need to go and
I can start excavating this area down
here to protect myself I don't need this
it's annoying it gets in my way
so all I gotta do is I just gotta keep
digging and eventually I'll find diamond
[Music]
I'm gonna make a chef's crafting table
I'm gonna grab more food
I don't have to come back up all the
time to be able to get everything that I
need I need some sticks all the wood
that I can get I don't have a lot of
wood can I really use all my wood okay I
got the food I got some wood it's enough
I'll make another crafting table and all
we don't die don't die that would be
terribly stupid I'd be very very very
stupid and I'm not stupid I'm stupid
I ain't stupid how do I make a box
there's my box do I have box box box
I got box I don't need to just the one
alright back to digging
I'm not a fine what are we get what do
we get what is this what is this what is
this what is this what is that what is
this what is this what is this oh this
is the hole that I dug in the ground ah
all right we're just gonna pretend like
it didn't get excited about that I'm
gonna find is that lava lava where
there's lava there's diamonds lava I'm
surrounded by lava this is the ideal
situation I la la la blah la blah la
blah la blah blah blah okay if I can get
to where this lava is then maybe I can
find a chasm and then the chasm can lead
me to something that'll be kind of like
a cave and it's at the right elevation
that I can get some film and that's the
objective
[Music]
sound the alarm sound the music cue
acquiring angels oh my god I am a genius
where there's lava there is indeed
riches to be had and found and there's
this stuff - whatever it is weird yellow
material oh yes please this this was
some deep lava - this was some hacking
lava oh my god the sweetest flavor the
sweetest taste that ever was toasted the
sweetest taste
[Music]
okay you can't mind diamond with a stone
pickaxe now see okay here's the thing
I looked it up I had to Google I did my
diamond disappear
apparently it's a meme listen I didn't
know I didn't know how would I know how
would I have known
I've played minecraft before and that's
probably been a rule from the beginning
but how would like see and delete
everything clicks in please I'm begging
you you have to delete clicks in please
you don't understand likes hint please
I'm sorry I asked you do that's super
cool time lapse Lucy please listen my my
reputation cannot recover yes please see
you have to delete everything I no one
could know all right
I'm lick seeing you ready to restart it
listen restarting all right here we go
all right I got my iron pickaxe and hope
I find diamond soon hey this is great
hey cool good oh man lava nearby hope I
find wowee wha yo yo yo yo oh no oh I
only get two I can't all right okay okay
okay all right so I've got diamond but
unfortunately I was an idiot and I will
readily admit that I'm an idiot
like I said before how would I have
known that being said I need to find one
more diamond because for some reason
that vein only had two is super-weird
Lee sometimes you luck out sometimes you
don't and I at that time I just didn't
luck out so I'll just have to find
another one and that's fine
oh please consume me consume me
onrushing lava whoa whoa where did you
qward what where do you come from I
didn't dig you out where did you come
from
okay cool good okay but good news is
good news we got diamonds so I went that
way let's now try to go this way
let's make another diamond
iron pickaxe at least so that we can
have a backup and let's get rid of the
demon stone pickaxe and never touch it
ever again
[Music]
oh there it is Oh God not my torch nah
there goes my torch Oh sh oh god oh god
oh god I almost threw my diamond in
there oh oh my god okay this is good
this actually looks like kind of an
alcove okay all done all done you done
you done good oh my symmetry I mean lick
see and sensor that lick seein please
replace it with something ah big waste
of my time is no diamonds here where's
the dough what did I miss this died
somehow miss this feel like I would have
seen this before oh my god oh my god
wouldn't I have put torches down if I
had seen this oh my god smells like
there could be diamonds in here maybe
well here's an actual ravine which is
nice under I don't think that's a
technical term hey dictionary it's an
addiction airy licks Ian please censor
that so there's some lapis up there but
that is not Dimond ooh eyes in the
darkness Oh baby baby oh baby oh who did
that no do not blow up my daddy do not
block do not bow do not blow up the
diamond you cannot you literally cannot
I will be so mad okay oh my god
okay I'm just getting rid of anything
else that might be here try me come big
waste and nothing that's what you are
and that's what you did
Hey ha ha all right enough enough
leave me me too my rib this is iron iron
iron run I run okay it may be just the
two that'll be enough that'll be enough
baby mission successful let's see it hit
the mission successful music that's the
good stuff right there that's good sweet
let's get out of here where did I come
from where am I going here yes here ha
ha ha my innate sense of direction my
impeccable sense of turning around I am
so good at the weir I am so good at the
that the doing perfect perfect this is
this is exactly what we've always wanted
this is exactly what everybody has
always wanted here and everyone wanted
for me I'm so happy that we can all be
here together to enjoy this moment I'm
out here baby let me out let me see the
Sun I want to see the beautiful Sun so
this is good this is good we learned a
valuable lesson and I think everyone can
forgive me for that and we've got four
diamond which is good because we can
make one pickaxe and then one diamond
shovel that's the perfect use for
diamond I think I think I definitely
think okay so we are in good shape
really good shape and now I shall craft
as this game is named minecraft thus
shall I mine and the shall I crash boom
baby that's what you call a diamond
pickaxe that is the CUDA gravy the coup
de Gras the coup de grunt oh there is
more that I can do there's like I know
that I can make like enchanting I never
understood the enchanting system I don't
know how to do that but I have earned my
first diamonds legitimately and my farm
is
[Music]
it's alright it's okay I can make like
can you make yeah you can make bone meal
and you can grow them right yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah enough for me to get
some bread at least and then this is
enough to make a few loaves and with a
few loaves I think that's a job well
done that's a job well done and it's a
day well done of working a job which I
did I worked a job
oh that's bread baby I got that bread I
don't need to eat it I can't eat it I'm
full but I made that bread and I got
that bread I did it proud of myself
proud of you proud of us how do you like
seem proud of me how do you but mostly
proud of me
and I don't have a roof but that's fine
so thank you everybody so much for
watching
there's been a bit of a chaotic
adventure though so far but I will keep
at it
also something some somebody said
something about glass panes I don't
think that's a real thing so thank you
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]